what's up guys welcome back to this
week's bitcoin weekly update this one
was kind of a quiet week but there's
lots of stuff going on in the macro
environment that is going to affect
bitcoin remember these updates are
brought to you by ftx click on the link
in the description to learn more about
them all right let's jump right in and
let's take a look at bitcoin the network
itself to get started first we can see
that bitcoin now trading below 22 000
coming in at the end of the week and
dropping in price bitcoin's market cap
today sits just over 400 billion dollars
the inflation rate remains unchanged at
1.76 percent more than 90 percent of
bitcoin supply has been issued and is
now in circulation the real exchange
volume over the last 24 hours just over
2 billion
and miners have been paid just under 20
million dollars in that same time period
to continue to secure the most
decentralized network in the world
bitcoin it's down about 68 from its
all-time high but it's up just over 22
percent from the cycle low if we compare
bitcoin gold and the s p 500 we find
that bitcoin down 55
over the last 12 months compared to gold
and the s p down two and four percent
respectively but over a two to ten year
period bitcoin remains the out performer
against both gold and the s p 500
next up we can look at the price closing
history sitting just below 22 000
bitcoin has actually been above this
level for only 11.5 percent of its
lifetime meaning that for about 88 of
bitcoin's life if you bought it and held
till today you would be in profit
next up we can take a look at the
compound annual growth rate bitcoin
coming in over the last decade
compounding every year at 115 percent
destroying gold s p 500 nasdaq and tlt
and of course the sharp ratio over the
last five years comes in at .88 meaning
that if you took bitcoin you put it into
a portfolio it would have a pretty
positive impact now the thing i want to
talk about this week that's really
important is the macro environment we've
seen here in the united states that
although inflation came down in july to
8.5 percent a lot of that was from the
base effect the change from june to july
was zero meaning that inflation didn't
actually come down all that happened was
it didn't go up it's a big difference
there we've also seen in other places
around the world take turkey as an
example which is 80
year-over-year inflation that the
central banks are starting to do kind of
wacky things the turkish central bank
actually decreased their interest rate
from 14 down to 13
that 100 basis point decrease in the
interest rate is leaving a lot of
economists and market commentators
scratching their heads if you have 80
percent inflation making the cost of
capital more expensive to try to bring
that inflation down but the turkish
president he believes that high interest
rates create inflation and so i don't
know where he got that idea from but
that one's kind of weird
next we can come back to the united
states and we see things like the
housing market falling off a cliff and
all of this feeds in to the big trade of
the fed being in control
what we mean by that is since inflation
went up over seven percent back at the
end of 2021 the federal reserve's been
talking tough they've been raising
interest rates and trying to conduct
quantitative tightening their belief is
that if they create tighter financial
conditions they'll destroy demand and of
course inflation will come down
now we haven't yet seen the inflation
actually come down that base effect they
may point to but we didn't actually see
a decrease in the inflation
what we have seen though is that asset
prices have fallen off a cliff and it
seems like correlations are going
towards one
investors believe that the fed is
serious that they remain committed to
raising interest rates and so they've
gone risk off they've sold things like
tech stocks bitcoin and other risk
assets and they fled to value stocks and
cash we can see with the dollar index
that it continues to strengthen against
the other basket of currencies that it
is compared to
but one question to ask yourself how
committed is the federal reserve
will the fed make it till the end of the
year by continuing to be aggressive in
their interest rate hikes and tighter
financial conditions or will we get to a
point where the federal reserve pivots
they wave the white flag and they return
to some sort of loose monetary policy i
don't know what that answer is but i
think there's a higher probability of a
pivot than most people are giving it
credit for that doesn't mean that it's
likely or guaranteed just means the
probability is higher than most people
think
and so if all of a sudden the fed was to
pause the quantitative tightening or
they were to return to loose monetary
policy that would serve as a tailwind
for something like bitcoin and many
other risk assets
right now the actual market itself
there's not a lot to talk about there
hasn't been a lot of change over the
last week but that macro environment
that's the big thing to watch and when
the fed pivots bitcoin will return
i hope that you're enjoying these weekly
updates i really enjoy putting them
together don't forget that it's now
brought to you by ftx us you can go
click on the link in the description to
learn more
ftx has incredibly cheap fees sometimes
as much as 85 cheaper than their
competitors and they've also introduced
digital stock trading which allows you
to go and buy stocks in the same place
that you buy bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies but there are no
transaction fees and no payment for
order flow for those digital stocks
meaning that you get best pricing and so
fts continues to innovate in financial
markets if you're interested go click on
the link in the description and sign up
today that's it for this week's update
and i'll see you guys next saturday hey
you did you like this video great make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time